when it's time for adventure it's time
for Superman
Alexander Salkind presents Christopher
Reeve and Richard Pryor in Superman 3
this time Richard Pryor has come to
Metropolis oh I'm sorry
and he's got something to sell he's the
best conman and the world's greatest
computer genius let me tell you
something I can't skate but then he
falls
for a scheme to turn the ultimate
computer into the ultimate weapon well
what will it do for me it would the only
thing you tell me to tell it to do a
machine so powerful baby
this day it can control the earth
Oh
now getting down to business change the
weather now something guaranteed and
reprogram Superman don't you never get
here
well hope you don't expect me to say
because I don't do that anymore
he didn't die asked you to kill the
Superman and you're telling me you
couldn't even do that one simple thing
ah right match to the game's over but
only the man who pulled the switch on
Superman oh I see I'm not with them
super good a full way mister can pull
the plug on super machine you're going
to go down in history as the man who
killed Superman no
thank you brother
Superman 3 what's true
this time is going to be the best time
of all